let's start with al with ari slipping me
molly let's start there
you slipped him on yeah dude what are
you doing
what are you doing how much that's
enough
interesting how did you do it where was
this it was at his house
we had a shot before we started i had to
empty out a capsule and [ __ ] put it
into a shop are you out of your mind
are you out of here yeah yeah yeah it
was it was great no it wasn't it was
great it was not you're making me go
on this [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] yeah joe
what kind of sociopath are we friends
with he did it
to punish me because i have to be sober
you don't give up molly
you're only giving up alcohol all right
i don't do molly because i just got back
from the doctor and he said hey it's
time to get healthy
i agree so yeah i agree you don't think
it's [ __ ] crazy that you would do
that
a bit yeah you're not doing it to like
your [ __ ] college roommate did you
even get the molly tested like where are
you buying this molly no i've done it
for my favorite
molly dealer bites his drink
yeah yeah high blood pressure high
cholesterol stayed out through guys
you're all
i would want to kill you he wanted to
for about 10 minutes until the probably
kicked in
and then he was fine
i had to fly that night i was on a
[ __ ] plane going like when's this
gonna [ __ ] stop
because i didn't know that orange juice
kicks it back up so i'm drinking
orange juice kicks it back vitamins you
drink a lot of orange juice generally
on the [ __ ] plane i'm drinking trying
to get hydrated because i'm on [ __ ]
molly
and so i'm drinking cheetos and orange
juice now i'm a big fan of your wife
i love her my wife would [ __ ] love
you
everything is on my watch at my house
but does she i i know that the whole
ahri
she hates his guts okay she hates him
in a way that not many people
she's all i she really hates him like
really hates him and that was what
bothered me about when he mollied me
was i was like i was like the it's so
funny he wants me to release the podcast
i will never release that [ __ ]
podcast
it does not make him look it not only
does it not make him look good
first of all it's proof that he
committed a crime that's number one
and and and number two it's just it he's
like it's funny it's funny and i know
it's not because you see in my eyes
a person who thinks i might die and that
you can see that and i see it
clearly but you also see like me
realizing
ari just [ __ ] up our friendship and i
and
and i and i was like that's what
bothered me the most out of it is like
when it happened i go
you just made it so my kids will hate
you and now my wife will hate you and
you can never come to my house and i can
never go on vacation with you
because my wife will always go don't go
i don't want you going yeah
and you also made it so i don't really
feel safe around you entirely
and i was like in the podcast i kept
going why would you do this
so for those of you don't know uh listen
to the joe rogan podcast yesterday
um our friend ari shafir your friends
coach
sizzle bird my friend
maybe not i don't know anymore after
this podcast we'll see um
our friend ari my friend ari um dosed
your husband with molly
he did during um a a
burp cast ari so from when i from when i
gathered from the story ari came over to
your home
because that's where burt shoots out of
the man cave shook hands with my
daughter
on his way to the man cave who was home
yeah
so your girls are how old is the
audience 13 and 15 13 and 15.
and um so they went in the man cave and
then ari said that he was preparing
shots for the two of them and bert saw
him
kind of with his back to bert and he's
like
brett was like i was filming you ari it
was on like in
on his instagram or something yeah and
then ari dosed him
with molly and then bert said that he
drank it and that yeah it tasted a
little
weird but whatever and then
they podcasted as he was i guess as the
molly was coming on
and that it ensued in severe panic
attacks
yes and so let's talk about it let's
talk about your end of that story
okay listen to joe rogan's show to get
bert and ari's side and
this is lance right right yeah i just
think anybody who
uh comes into someone's house with their
kids there and
drugs an adult in charge has
there's something wrong with that what
do you mean totally normal
totally normal ari i mean you come over
and dose you're
you guys are in your 40s i know right
that's what i kept saying
it's not like you're at a rave you know
you're not at a rave you're at my house
i was cooking dinner for bert to have
dinner with our kids because he was
leaving that night to go
on tour and bert wouldn't come in the
house and i was like what's going on
he's not coming in the house i don't
understand he's
why is this podcast going on forever um
and
he kept going stay in the house just
keep everybody in the house
they usually podcast inside the man cave
but for whatever reason this time they
decided to do it
on like our outdoor furniture oh i think
cause bert was saying he was admiring
the sunset
maybe it was beautiful it was intense
that's what he said
it was a beautiful and he's like despite
okay yeah i know he said i just wanted
to stare at the trees
and i couldn't i was like what's going
on but i i didn't know what was going on
right so um until i invited aria to stay
for dinner i was like i cook dinner come
stay for dinner he's like no no
that's i'm good i'm gonna leave and then
bert told me
and i was like wow there are
i mean burke could have had a heart
attack he could have had a stroke that
was pure
molly and he um he's on blood pressure
medication
he's 47 years old and imagine
if that had happened with isla home you
know right
that's just there's just no thought
outside of ari's agenda
there was no like have the agenda and
then get to the place and go oh
ooh there are 13 year old kids here oh
wait this may not be a great plan maybe
i should rethink this
right like so so aria so ari leaves and
that's when you realize
oh god no burke called me in the
bathroom and he said i need to talk to
you alone
so he told me in the he
he very smartly said i'm going to tell
you something's going to make you really
upset
oh so he yeah
put your feelings aside and take care of
me okay
because i am having massive panic
attacks yeah so i need you to know this
before i tell you what's going on and i
was i was looking at him going
his his pupils are like
pinheads what's going on this is have
you done molly before no
ecstasy or never done no i've never done
any drugs i've just drank
um i've smoked pot four times and threw
up all four times so i was like
maybe not for me are you dosing bert you
want to dive into this
first i think that bert likes any hype
that he can get i think he's okay with
it in the end i think it was a little
risque in the beginning
my problem is doing it around his family
if
if it was like on the road or something
that's whatever because they're so close
he did it that's whatever
the problem is there's no consequence
like you've already did that to me
you're gonna get your ass what
stress around my kids there's gonna be
repercussions that's the problem he
knows bert's not gonna do anything yeah
you do that to rogan there's gonna be
repercussions yeah you do that to tom
it's probably gonna be repercussions
but bert's so fun and playful that bert
you know
and bert does they're close though so
it's like they're boy like
you would never do that to me right yeah
that would be crazy you would never do
that to me
but again i i don't know the
relationship well enough
but you and me are close you're one of
my best friends if you
brian or rogan death to me dude i'd have
to put my hands on you yeah
especially in front of my kids i would
do it
just to feel something you know people
aren't feeling it huh
sting it yeah but again but if i
you know ari they they play around and
play around like that right it's like i
don't know the relationship so if that's
how they play around
who am i to say they shouldn't have done
it well he's like the santa claus kind
of of drugs he like kind of shows up
people don't know if he's real and then
he [ __ ] drugs you you know
um i know bert was i i heard bert was
upset but then he seems all right but
then he seems all right with it yeah
so i thought he said he said he had some
medical problems or something but he's
always had those i think since i've
known oh god
that's his weight right yeah yeah and he
was like what's up about his heart yeah
yeah that's what he's doing they said
they were going to replace his heart at
one point
oh [ __ ] with like a calf's heart or
something this lasts over october i got
mollied
right before sober october started i'm
just gonna ask how sick of talking about
that are you no i just started talking
about it on stage
oh okay
and everyone just kind of was like they
knew i wasn't it wasn't like
it wasn't super funny to me when it
happened like it wasn't like you'd
expect
you know comedian to be like dude that
was [ __ ] crazy right no no no no
correction nobody in the nobody in the
[ __ ]
world would ever think that that was
right for those people listening or
don't know
bert had a comedian arie shafir over at
his house they were recording a podcast
bert's kids were [ __ ] home he had to
go to the airport
shortly like shortly after the podcast
that very same day
and they were like hey let's you know
let's have a couple drinks together
mellow
and so aries fear [ __ ] doses burt's
drink with [ __ ]
molly so now all of a sudden bert's
[ __ ]
like uh having a an intense hardcore
drug
experience in front of his [ __ ] kids
having to go to the airport to [ __ ]
get on an airplane
[ __ ] rolling on [ __ ] molly nobody
thinks that's [ __ ] cool
the guy on the flight next to me got the
best back massage ever
no i just started talking about it
because uh uh rogan was like hey man you
can you should you you can talk about
that on stage and i was i was just
right with the implication being that
you thought that i didn't know how to
approach you
i don't know yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] with ari and
people just start disliking him
and then on time and then on top of that
his
[ __ ] thing with the kobe comments
like
and then i mean dude he goes hard in the
pain i guess
you know you know i was thinking about
that we were driving over to do this
with you and i was thinking about that
like you know
where do i stand on on all that you know
like we're like i
i don't want to like pile on a whole
canceled culture like let's
like harm this guy and harm his
reputation i'm not i'm not out to
to do that i'm not the [ __ ] police
but
we're the one thing out of all that like
i'm not gonna say oh that it wasn't a
joke it wasn't funny like i mean that's
just subjective
what's not subjective for me and it's
about that being on brand thing
is him saying i was hacked oh
no no yeah but no but that was actually
a joke
that was the joke was it was such a
horrible statement that he wrote
oh hey guys i was hacked and and then
you know i
i'm definitely not going to sit here and
defend ari but i i have in the past
um i think what [ __ ] him up was the
video
if he had just left the tweet the video
what video is weird it's like remember
when
you heard ray rice hit his wife and
you're like oh
he's and they've dealt with it it's
gonna be fine he'll be back next week
then they show
you saw the video of everything his wife
you're like oh that's a little different
yeah
like [ __ ] he [ __ ] hits her
hit her he
i've never been hit that hard in my
[ __ ] life
and then and so i think ari's video was
was
videos so much worse than that in that
case
and oddly enough but there's somewhere
in your heart you're thinking of dosing
bird a second time
sure i don't think i have multiple plans
i got my mistake was not getting his
wife that way
she got upset at me because she felt
left out i think that was the biggest
issue
i don't know i'm not going to toast him
again and that's the opportunity to run
say something no no i'm not ghost him
again they would be [ __ ]
hilarious like like in a bar in new york
if you got him again there would be but
i'm not going to do it but it would be
hilarious
priceless